the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so if you guys don't remember me I'm one
of your TAS I'm Tina number three that's
what I call myself I'm Kayne and I'll be
teaching your lesson today because well
mics in Russia so yeah yeah so I know
you guys had your first exam a couple of
days ago how did that go okay sounds
good alright so we will talk about it
but because you guys just had a super
kind of intense exam we just want to
give you guys a break so today I'll be
teaching you guys a little bit of
nuclear energy so this lesson won't be
super in-depth there won't be a lot of
crazy intense math actually there won't
be any crazy intense not because we just
want to give you guys a break you guys
are gonna be starting up full cycle on
Friday with really cool topics like
stopping power so for now it's just kind
of like it's a very expression over a
couple fun facts I'm a couple guys might
already know some of the concepts I'm
mentioning because you guys are
intelligent people but I walked into MIT
not knowing a single thing about nuclear
energy and I was like I wish someone
could have told me these things um so
that's what I want to do for you today
okay so I'm going to be talking about
kind of like the functionality and the
benefits and the problems associated
nuclear but first let's start with a
very brief history in a nutshell so
between 1895 to 1945 that's one really
cool people were developing nuclear
science so people like Madame Curie or
like Fermi etc they were all designing
this nuclear science like they were
developing it which is pretty cool most
of this development happened between
1939 to 1945 doesn't really want to take
a gander as to why why will it yeah
exactly but what field in Manhattan
Project which is what war - yeah exactly
so World War two was happening during
those times and they were trying to
develop the atom bomb which is why the
majority of nuclear science was
developed between these like five or six
years then 1945 to 1960 they entered a
phase of like well the war's over now at
what do we do with ourselves so luckily
they decided to redirect this science
into using it for energy and harnessing
it in a controlled fashion so mainly the
focus was actually for naval submarines
but they often realized like we can use
this for like energy as well free
electricity as well so there's a lot of
really cool things that happened in
between these years so in 1951 the first
nuclear reactor to produce electricity
was the experimental breeder reactor the
Eevee
one was developed and designed and
operated and actually kind of worked it
was created by Argonne National Labs
which is in Idaho and they actually
still exist so if you want to go work
there this summer you totally can boom
and then in 1953 President Eisenhower he
created something called atoms for peace
so this is just a program that advocated
using nuclear for things that were
peaceful such as electricity instead of
like nuclear weapons and stuff also 1953
was the creation of mark 1 so mark 1 is
the first prototype naval reactor that
was created it was created in a March
and then finally in 1954 the first
nuclear-powered submarine the USS
Nautilus was launched and it's up and
running so lots of cool things happened
between this time but the real heyday of
nuclear was actually between 1960 to
1975 so during the span of 15 or so
years this was like the real commercial
energy boom
people like Westinghouse were creating
nuclear reactors I think the first one
was called Anki Rho is a 250 megawatt
electric
nuclear power plant which is like not
insignificant for like a time like the
70s
so other different companies and other
different countries were doing this as
well basically there was this huge boom
and nuclear energy so if you look at
this little chart over here this is
nuclear reaction reaction construction
throughout the years so if you look in
this little chunk you can see what a
massive peak there was this is like when
everyone was building nuclear reactors
people thought oh super Jazzy and
everyone's tried to jump on that
unfortunately all good things have to
come to an end though from 1975 to 2002
which is about this chunk over here you
can see a massive decline and then you
can see that nothing really happens
between the 90s in the 2000s other than
the fact that we were all born but no
new nuclear reactors were being
commissioned during this time and then
today we're kind of I say we're back but
basically we're entering what people
like to call a nuclear Renaissance which
is between like this chunk over here you
can see that there's been a slight
increase in nuclear reactors being
produced but basically there's been a
whole new push for creating more
advanced reactors and currently China
India and South Korea they are the main
like players in this game so China
itself has 32 offer directors operating
at the moment and they have 20 more
Commission like literally right now
which is kind of insane Sam do you guys
have any questions about
this alright so what causes like nuclear
resurgence this is a perfect time to
talk about why nuclear power school
again you guys probably know this but
the main reason is sustainability so
right now we've entered a phase in time
where people are started to realize that
we've done damage to our environment and
we gotta fix this so global warming is a
thing I promise you it's actually saying
and basically we're looking for a way to
produce electricity without creating
such a large carbon footprint so if you
look at this chart over here you can see
that this is where nuclear lies in the
amount of carbon that it produces per
what's a unit per gigawatt hour of
electricity when you look at that in
comparison to a coal and natural gas
which is our two primary sources of
energy at the moment you can see that
this is definitely more attractive so
the statistic is actually that nuclear
creates 75 times less carbon emission
then coal does and 35 times less than
natural gas does which is incredible and
amazing so that's the main reason why
we're going for nuclear
well there's out there kind of other
kinds of really good reasons one is the
amounts power output you guys actually
calculated this yourself and pset1 you
know just how much power or energy comes
out from one fission reaction um so just
so you guys can double check to be got
that statistic right and a piece set it
turns out that you 35 40 3.5 million
times more energy than burning one
kilogram of coal does um so you can see
that you definitely need a lot less fuel
in a nuclear reactor than you do in a
normal like coal burning reactor and
then finally the last thing would be
energy security um so one of the good
things about nuclear is I can serve as a
good base load source of energy so if
you're working the energy sector you
probably see this chart all the time of
like time verses like energy that's
being consumed and it's kind of like
fluctuating like little mass that stays
like fairly constant about at certain
times of the day like you need more
energy than usual so this is just kind
of like the energy demand during the day
that's what this chart kind of crudely
depicts so nuclear power is able just to
provide a good base load source that
means like it can provide constant
energy at a really high level all the
time so this is why we kind of want to
replace coal and natural gas with
nuclear because it can take this role
other alternative forms of energy might
be better for the environment it might
be safer and things like that but it's
not really able to do this so for
example if you want to replace all the
coal burning fire plants with solar
panels if it's not sunny that day you're
kind of like
look right like you can't produce energy
if it's not something outside somewhere
for wind if it's not windy outside
you're not getting any electricity
luckily for nuclear it doesn't have to
rely on any of these factors you can
continuously produce energy right so you
guys have any questions about what I've
mentioned awesome so now we'll talk a
little bit about reactor types I'm just
telling you guys about some of the main
ones and how they work so how people
like to divide up the reactor types is
in generations so generation one which
is all the way over there that refers to
the like the trial reactors these are
the ones that didn't really produce all
that much electricity at all they're
more of proofs look they're more proof
of concept kind of things um so that
would be like the mark one that I want
you to guys earlier now we move on to
generation two so generation two is
actually what most of us reactors like
the category that most u.s. reactors
fall into so these were developed
between like the seventies and like the
80s ish and these are the ones that are
functioning mostly today and then we
have generation 3 3 + & 4 so these are
the new types of reactors that people
are trying to build to create several
improvements but we'll talk about them a
little bit more later so I want to start
off with light water reactors because
well these are the reactors that are
most common in the United States so
light water reactors are LWR s are
mostly broken up into two sub categories
boiling water reactors and pressurized
water reactors so how you guys can think
about reactors is that honestly they're
just kind of glorified steam turbines
that's what that's what they're doing so
let's start with boiling water reactors
so boiling water reactors or PWRs
comprise about 21% of you reactors that
are located and working in the United
States so it's a really really simple
mechanism and we can walk through that
right now so over here this little
nubbin right over here so this is the
fuel core so this is what the inside of
a fuel core looks like that picture over
there um so the fuel core is basically
just a bunch of rods of like uranium
sometimes it's clad in something like
zirconium and there's also control rods
to help slow down the process so uranium
undergoes what
yassuh fission so what gets released
during a vision
and cool and neutrons awesome so those
three things are all like flying around
inside the reactor core at the moment as
the uranium undergoes fission
so the isotopes we just kind of let them
be like I don't I'm not completely sure
what we do with and we might folk to
them out but I think they just kind of
hang out there the heat obviously goes
to create power talked about in just a
second but the neutrons come flying
around so those other neutrons can
stimulate other fuse other efficient and
the control rods are there to prevent
like to make sure that there's not too
many fission's happening at the troll
rod at a certain time i and the fuel
core at a certain time so anyway going
back to the heat so the heat that gets
created during these nuclear fission's
that goes and heats up the water so this
is just one loop of water basically so
the water flows through the core and
heats it up it creates steam so the
steam goes and spins the turbine the
turbine create electricity and it comes
back and gets recognized that's
literally it that's all that happens
during a PWR
yeah that's that's actually just it so a
cool thing about the BWR is because it's
so simple it's also incredibly well not
incredibly what is the cheapest option
out there for creating nuclear power I'm
one of the downsides it's just that it
might not be as energy efficient as it
possibly could be or not be able to
create as much power as I possibly could
if it was a core technology but yeah oh
and another downside is that because we
have the nuclear material interacting
with the water and so this is a coolant
pump right I mean this is the core tube
so this is basically connected to a lake
or an ocean or some other source of cold
water and that runs through the primary
loop to cool down the water and
reconnect it to steam if there ever is a
breach between these two the chances of
leaking nuclear material into the
environment exists like it's not high
per se but with me wrs there is a higher
chance of leaking radioactive material
into the varmint so that's one of the
downsides that BW RS um do you guys have
any questions about this awesome
um so I just want to show you guys this
picture again because here's the
underside of a PWR I make it sound like
it's super simple and like a walk in the
park but this is actually the amount of
technology that goes into one of these
reactors like look at all those wires I
don't even know what they all do but
it's kind of insane so yeah so the next
kind of reactor that falls under the
light water reactor category is the
pressurized water reactors
so PWRs are actually more more important
if you lo the BW RS so remember BW o RS
comprise about 21% of the reactors in
the United States on PWRs comprise about
60% of the reactors in the United States
but they are functionally essentially
the same and it's just slightly more
complicated
um so over here we have our fuel core
again and again it's all it's doing is
heating up water with its fission
reactions but this time this water is
pressurized so does anyone know why you
would want to pressurize the water yeah
yeah exactly
so when you increase the pressure you're
also increasing the boiling point of the
water and that allows you to function at
even higher temperatures than if you're
working with a BWR which gives you more
energy efficiency you guys will learn
all about that into 805 by the way so
yeah so it heats up this pressurized
water and this pressurized water goes
into a second loop which again just
heats up water that creates into steam
that sends a turbine that crazy
electricity it gets me condensed etc and
that's again all that there really is so
one of the upsides of using a PWRs like
I mentioned the higher efficiency but
also the chance of leaking nuclear
material into the environment becomes
mitigated because you have two separate
loops with the nuclear fuel being more
isolated from the environment um if
there is a breach between like the
condenser loop and the secondary loop
not a big deal like nothing really bad
happens you'd have to have breaches in
both the loops which is very unlikely to
happen yeah so do you guys have any
questions about those two yeah
I'm not completely sure but if you
google it you should be able to find it
really easily
so those next pictures again just to
show you that like I make it sound
really simple and like a walk in the
park but it's really not there's a lot
going on so this picture over here is
basically just showing that there are a
lot of redundancy systems inside these
reactors like we don't just have one
single primary loop and if it fails it
fails we actually have four at the same
time and this is just called the N minus
2 redundancy something like that so the
next kind is something much cooler oh
it's called a heavy water reactor
actually it's just a little bit cooler
but the main heavy water reactor that
everyone can kind of think of on their
minds is can do which is the one that's
located in Canada the only difference
between heavy water reactors and the
light water reactors I mentioned before
is that it uses heavy water instead of
light water does anyone know what heavy
water is yeah exactly so it's just a
terraeum oxide so remember I'm sorry
this might seem a name but this is water
right um and this is heavy water where
the dia is just a hydrogen with two two
atomic particles instead so one proton
and one Neutron so the reason why they
decide to use heavy water instead of
light water is because heavy water has a
much lower absorption cross-section than
light water does um so what this means
is that when neutrons are flying around
in the reactor like there is a chance of
it hitting a fission product and under a
piece of fissionable material and
undergoing fission but there's also a
chance that the water that surrounds it
will absorb that Neutron so if that
Neutron gets pulled out of the system
you're not able to create any more
fission's this is actually kind of a bad
thing because the whole point of a
nuclear reactor is to create heat
envisioned so we don't want them to
neutrons to be absorbed you can see if
you look at those statistics um you can
see that the absorption cross section of
h2 our deuterium is like point zero zero
zero five two barns in comparison to h1
which is 0.33 two barns
so I'm bad at math but I think it's like
680 times less right maybe anyway so you
can see why deuterium would be a good
option for this so because it's
absorbing less there is
because it has a chance of absorbing
less neutrons as it undergoes its
processes um you're actually able to use
a lower enriched uranium which is really
great because that lowers fuel cost yeah
but the main downside of this is that
even though you're lowering your fuel
costs deuterium is really expensive it's
about a thousand or so dollars per
kilogram which is kind of ridiculous
because a kilogram of water is really
not much at all you know so even though
your counter you act like you're
counteracting the lowered fuel cost with
a higher water cost also because your
act you're using your reactor with lower
in rich uranium you actually have to
change out your feel more often that
fuel gets spent more quickly I'll
describe that in just a second and
therefore you just have to keep
replacing it more often than you would
for a normal weight light water reactor
um questions about this one oh I forgot
to mention but aside from that
everything else with the heavy water
reactors and the PWRs they're the same
mechanisms and then finally we're going
to move on to breeder reactors so
breeder reactors are a really cool idea
and they were most popular between like
the 50s and the 60s ish at the very
beginning of creating nuclear reactors
so what breeder reactors are or again
there's some sure the same thing as
light water reactors I mentioned to you
guys before but instead now there's two
little chunks of extra material so do
you guys know what the difference is
between fits all for Tahoe and
fissionable materials cool all right so
[Music]
all right so let's start with the Samba
turn so fizzy material is basically just
the material that has build me to
undergo fission with a thermal Neutron
so basically when the thermal Neutron
gets absorbed by this fissionable
material it's going to undergo a fission
um makes a lot of sense right so do you
guys happen to remember what the energy
of a thermal Neutron is you guys
calculated this in pset 1 huh lower than
that yeah a point ot5 easy like super
letter do and while we're at it how do
you calculate this
what some constant time Steve go shoot
so main example with the fissile
material would be u-235 and plutonium
239 there's four in total but those are
the two most important ones so this is
the main fuel that is inside a nuclear
reactor but it's not all just u-235 like
you guys have heard of oh [ __ ] what's
called enrichment right like in Richmond
is basically the amount of DES all
material versus the amount of other
fissionable material so moving on to
fissionable material so Fischer I'm on
terrible fissionable material is just
material that is able to undergo fission
after the absorption absorption of a
more energetic Neutron um so that's all
it is
so that's all it is so an example of
fissionable material that's inside the
other reactors at the same time is u-238
so if it u-238 absorbs a thermal Neutron
it's probably gonna do much but if it
absorbs a neutron of about like I would
say like 2 MeV then it's more willing to
undergo a fission and then finally we
have fertile material so for a time
material is the basis for breeder
reactors but fertile material is just
material that absorbs a neutron and then
is able to become a piece of fissile
material
so for our purposes the main types of
fertile material we use are u-238 and
thorium-232 so if you look at these
processes you can see that you - they're
a absorbs a neutron becomes you 239
undergoes a beta decay to come to
neptunium and undergoes one more beta
decay to become the beautiful plutonium
239 if we start with thorium 232 instead
absorbs a neutron becomes thorium 233
undergoes a beta decay to come
protactinium becomes uranium 233 which
is another sound material by the way
through a series of beta decays mom so
that's what breeder reactors are doing
they're adding extra chunks of uranium
238 and extra chunks of thorium 232 into
the reactor so if one of the neutrons so
imagine okay if you're looking at the
little fuel core there's a bunch of
neutrons are flying around and he other
isotopes and things like that so some of
the neutrons will go and create other
visions with the material that's hanging
out in the red but other neutrons might
escape and when they escape instead of
going into the water and dissipating and
never to be seen again or being
reflected the instead create more
fissile material um so you can I
understand why this is a kind of an
attractive idea is that you're creating
your own fuel you're able to work at a
higher fuel efficiency um because you
don't need to add in as much fissile
materials that's you would for a normal
light water reactor so people were
really fascinated with this idea like I
said in the 50s and 60s because back in
the day they legitimately thought that
we would run out of u-235 but luckily in
the 16 we we discovered that we have a
lot more uranium ore than we thought we
did we're probably not gonna run out
anytime soon
and after that discovery people were not
nearly as interested in breeder reactors
the reason being is that one because
there's just this extra material that's
hanging out this extra material could be
more fissile material I creates more
reactions it's not nearly as
energy-efficient my part of power
efficient and it's also slightly more
expensive because you're not being able
to be power efficient and it also is
better on paper than ever is in reality
so on paper you're like oh this is great
because I can just create more fissile
materials I never need to add more this
is never really truly sustainable they
always have to keep adding more fissile
materials because it's not as perfect as
I want it to be
any questions about these things cool
beans
and then finally we're gonna move on to
generation four reactors so generation
four reactors are all the new kind of
reactors that people want to build so
the primary objective for these new
designs of reactors like the ones I just
told you guys about they're all good and
well but we want to make them better
right we want to make them cleaner and
safer and more cost-effective keep them
robust yet sustainable and also make
them more resistant to people being able
to divert materials into creating
nuclear weapons um so yeah so here are
the six kinds of generation form reactor
types that were deemed to be the the
most the most promising so there's gas
cooled fast reactors LED cool fast
reactors molten salt reactors sending
cool fast reactors high temperature part
of very high temperature gas reactors
and supercritical water cooled reactors
so I'm gonna be honest with you guys I
don't know all that much about these and
I don't want to like spew out
information that might potentially be
false so if you guys aren't interested
one you can talk to other lab members
people in this department I know they're
mostly Mike's group actually a lot of
people Mike's coop are working on what
one salt reactors so you guys can like
go ahead and ask them off that or if you
understand you can read more about them
with this hyperlink that I included over
here hopefully he will post the slides
online and you guys can just click it
and there's a awesome source all about
these different kinds of reactors any
questions
I'm pretty sure that they're just kind
of proof of concept stage right now like
there aren't any that are producing
electricity and like in the United
States at least good question all right
so all the things that we've mentioned
before that like how great nuclear yes
and all the cool applications of it and
how simple and easy reactors are why
aren't we using more of it so currently
in the u.s. there's only 99 operating
reactors that are producing electricity
which makes up about 19 percent or about
20 percent of the total electricity
output in the United States the main
players are still you would imagine coal
and natural gas so this is actually even
worse in other in the rest of the world
and the rest of the world there's only
about 440 reactors federal power three
countries it produces only fourteen
percent of the global electricity so
these proportions are pretty low and
you're wondering like why aren't we
using more nuclear power
what exactly is holding us back so it
turns out that the main things that are
holding us back is just social social
economic and therefore like government
has a tense to start using nuclear power
or more often so the main reason why
we're a little bit hesitant to start
using more nuclear power is because of
safety issues so nuclear weak none of us
could argue that nuclear is like 100
percent safe it actually does have some
dangers associated with it which is why
it's so important that we're doing what
we're doing but if you guys look at this
chart that I showed you guys in like the
first or second slide um you'll notice
that there are these events um listed
above what are these words Three Mile
Island Chernobyl Fukushima what are they
yeah so there's some of our biggest
nuclear accidents that we've experienced
through history and you can see that
after a nuclear accident you can see a
pretty steep decline and the amount of
nuclear reactors that are being
commissioned so this is especially
noticeable at Three Mile Island which is
essentially the first nuclear reactor as
an accident that we all had to go
through and you can see that after Three
Mile Island you can see this massive
steep like this massive decline in the
amount of nuclear actors being
commissioned this is probably
causational we can pretty much assume
that and then you can see that in
chernobyl once you know what happened
you can see like this also another
massive decline
and again a Fukushima once again like
the amount of reactors being
commissioned after the accident just
declines dramatically so I'm assuming
you guys probably don't know exactly
what happened during each of these
accents like you probably know that they
exist but like what happened during them
so if you do know sorry but if you don't
know you're about to know home so Three
Mile Island which is the first one it
happened in 1979 on March 28th so Three
Mile Island reactor is a PWR located in
Pennsylvania so during this time it
underwent a core meltdown so the cause
of this is just the fact that there was
some kind of mechanical or electrical
system that prevented coolant water from
being pumped into the primary system so
because there wasn't enough water coming
to cool up the core the core began to
overheat so as the temperature of the
core Rises the pressure also Rises so
they notice this and they're like oh
shoot we got to fix that so luckily
there is like a little emergency valve
that you can see in this little
animation gets opened up and pressure
gets released so that's all good and
well um but unfortunately after the
pressures release you should close the
valve again and continue operation but
it became stuck so this valve became
stuck and they didn't realize that
became stuck because their their
equipment and their instrument ation
wasn't able to take that so they
continue operating again but this style
was open um so there's actually water
that was getting leaked out of this
primary this primary loop so because the
water was getting leaked they noticed
that oh shoot the pressure is dropping
well what do you do when the pressures
dropping apparently you have to make
sure that there's not enough there's not
too many vibrations I could damage the
reactors so they shut off the coolant
pumps so well they lower the operation
of the quota pumps so now there's water
leaking out so the core is getting
hotter but then they also took out the
water that's usually used to cool the
reactor core so again it's also getting
hotter so this combination events led to
a core meltdown so the core amount of
town um that's never a good thing by the
way um so yeah and yeah so the core
meltdown the reactor wasn't able to
operate anymore but luckily at Three
Mile Island there was containment that
prevented radioactive isotopes from
leaving the system so they actually took
a brief survey when I'd be surfing I was
probably a long long experience but I
realized that the two million people who
are around two
Island at the time within like a
two-mile radius or like like maybe like
a 30-mile radius or something more like
that they realized that they didn't get
much dose at all they collected about a
total of one milligram more dose than
usual so to put that in perspective and
x-rays six mil around so really nothing
that bad happened at Three Mile Island
other than they had to shut it down and
they had to do expensive repairs but
people weren't hurt the environment
wasn't damaged it wasn't that bad of a
situation I think the effect was bigger
and concept than it was in actual damage
um questions about Three Mile Island
accident alrighty
the next reactor accident the Big Kahuna
I like to call it is Chernobyl so on
April 25th 1986 RBMK reactor that was
located in Ukraine exploded so what they
were doing at Chernobyl during the time
of this explosion is that they were
actually running ironically enough
safety tests oh they're running the
reactor low power to see how it behaves
so at low power I don't think they quite
realized this but the coolant pumps in
the reactor we're also powered by the
nuclear reactor being generated so if
they were burning this at low power the
coolant pumps weren't getting enough
energy to properly cool the fuel core so
that was unfortunate and they realized
that this is a bad thing so the reactor
start to go
supercritical so one they realize that
the reactor was creating a lot more
fission's than it should have been
creating they decide to insert the
control rods so thank goodness we have
these high absorption control rods to
slow things down right for some reason I
don't not completely share why they did
this but rpm chains they have graphite
tips control rods so as they lower the
control rods into the water this
graphite tip which doesn't effectively
absorb neutrons it displaced a little
bit too much water that was necessary
and that cost the first explosion so
what's super duper critical it caused
the first explosion that renoble
oh by the way um then for some reason
like a couple minutes later there's a
second explosions they're not completely
sure why the second explosion happened
to the state we can't really pinpoint
why it could have been like building up
helium or just a ton of other fission
reactions but there's a second explosion
that actually just blew this entire core
apart so that kind of stunk but it did
sum up the whole reaction because the
super critical mass was all blown apart
and it was no longer supercritical it
was fine the whole debacle stopped but
unfortunately there
was a lot of radioactive radioactive
isotopes being spent in environment um
first of all Chernobyl didn't have the
same kind of containment the Three Mile
Island had so this these isotopes are
just able to go everywhere and also the
second explosion had a lot of steam with
it that carry these isotopes even
further than they probably should have
gone um so if you're looking at the sad
statistics of Chernobyl it turned out
that 28 highly exposed reactor staff and
emergency workers died from this
radiation or from thermal burns during
this time and officials also believe
that there's about seventy thousand
seven thousand cases of thyroid cancer
that occurred because of Chernobyl
they're pretty sure I was Chernobyl
because these are all cases that
happened and people who are less than 18
years old so you guys know that no one
really lives near Chernobyl at the
moment um it's kind of been deemed
unlivable
because these radioactive isotopes
literally went everywhere in this
environment like it was in the water it
was in the plant
it's not safe to live there it's a
pretty radioactive environment luckily
we see that there are animals coming
back now if you look on National
Geographic calm there's like little deer
roaming around Chernobyl um but it's
been about like how long has it been
like 3040 years people are advised to
live here still search for noble was
terrible questions yeah oh yeah sorry so
um you guys will learn all about
criticality in a little bit but
basically when I say supercritical it
just means that there's way too many
fission reactions happening yeah
I think I might have skipped to detail
it wasn't being cooled enough so the
water was evaporating and then it became
supercritical because they're not enough
neutrons were being slowed down and
absorbed my bad I'm sorry good all right
so the next reactor accident um that we
were all alive for which is cool oh and
what's Fukushima Daiichi so if we could
she would ITA happened in 2011 on March
11th and Fukushima died Luka Shima is in
Japan so these reactors these are I
think these are pressurized water
reactors yeah I think so um so following
a major earthquake the generators that
um pardon yeah so following a major
earthquake the things that were cooling
the core they broke I think they're just
like power generators on the side that
did um yeah they broke the coolant pumps
so there wasn't enough water being able
to go to the field course this is a very
similar problem as you can see that in
all these instances of the reactor
incidents it's just kind of like the
fuel core was misbehaving and we weren't
able to get enough coolant water to it
so following the earthquake these
coolant pumps broke they're like oh
that's ok what we can do is we have
backup generators to continue running
the pumps it'll be all okay
nothing will happen we're all good and
then a tsunami hit so it's a 15-foot
tsunami I think I think that 15 meter
tsunami oh good gosh Oh so 15 meter
tsunami hit and it broke the generators
and then at that point they're like oh
no so they had no other done see factors
to continue pumping cool water into the
fuel core so again there wasn't enough
water in the core it became
supercritical it began to melt so the
fuel rods began to melt but this is
actually another additional bad thing so
the water was evaporating critics team
they're so Konya the fuel rods were
coated with surco diem so what you guys
might not know is that one zirconium and
steam interact with each other that's
not a good thing it starts to explode so
the as you can see the reactors at
Fukushima Daiichi began to explode there
was radioactive radioactive isotopes
being spread out all around the country
you guys probably saw the lovely flow
charts of like the radioactivity flowing
out from Japan and making it to
California and contaminating your fish
and stuff like that but luckily no one
was directly hurt by burns or
radioactive exposure alright questions
about Fukushima
so aside from these safety issues um
these safety issues that happen they get
elevated in the news quite a lot so
these are mainly the things that people
who don't really have any background in
nuclear energy hear about nuclear energy
they're like oh shoot well this thing is
going to explode every twenty years like
why do we keep using this reactor
accidents are actually pretty rare like
if you think about it it's been about 60
or 70 years we have 440 reactors
happening other countries there's three
main accidents have happened but because
these are the things that people get
ingrained into their mind thank you news
stations people think that nuclear
reactors are incredibly dangerous and
that's why we have the social hesitancy
which is why we aren't able to get
enough government funding and which is
why there's all these bureaucracy
loopholes to jump through which is why
nuclear power isn't more of a thing
makes sense yeah another issue that's
associated with nuclear power is nuclear
waste so what in the world do we do with
it so first of all the main thing in
nuclear waste is spent fuel so like I
mentioned you guys the spent fuel rods
are made out of uranium oxide but after
undergoing a much officiants these
Urania these uranium particles get
transformed into other isotopes that
aren't fishable or fertile or even
remotely bizarre right so we eventually
have to replace them and add a new rods
and this is a process that happens every
late 12 or so years I'm not completely
sure and let statistic but the main
issue is like what do we do with all
this material so the mysterious material
that comes out is pretty radioactive
it's also incredibly hot so it can be
dangerous if someone decides to they
come and eat it oh so that's why we got
to figure out a way to dispose it so the
primary way of disposing of this spent
fuel is putting it into spent fuel pools
so spent fuel pools are just giant tanks
the water that exists at the reactor so
these tanks of water are mixed with I
believe it's boron which is the neutron
absorber let me simply just put the
spent fuel rods all the way at the
bottom of the pool so this pool is that
like 20 meters high I think and this is
actually a really good solution because
the water in the pool it cools down the
reactor rods um and also prevents a lot
of neutrons from escaping because water
is a really great neutron moderator you
guys all know this I'm gonna turn down
it's actually fairly safe apparently you
can go swimming on the top of the
reactor so that fuel pool and you'll be
okay I'm not be exposed to too much
radiation if you want so yeah
so this is the main solution that people
have been using for years but they
realize that this isn't super
sustainable because the amount of space
that we have and they spent fuel pools
is not infinite like we have way too
much spent fuel to be able to just
continue to store it and they spent fuel
pools so like shoot kind of find another
solution so the next solution was
something called dry cask storage so dry
cask storage is just a way to keep this
spent fuel surrounded by an inert gas so
and it's held inside a cask a cache just
being probably like a steel drum that's
like bolted and welded shut and there's
additional pieces of shielding around it
like cement and then etc so there's just
like gigantic tanks basically that are
sitting outside so they just put them
outside the reactor as you can see it's
just it looks like it's sitting in a
parking lot outside the reactor and so
this is a okay solution um so basically
what they do is they take the spent fuel
let it sit in their pool for about a
year or so maybe two or three years and
then they're able to take it out because
at that point it's significantly less
radioactive because you know you guys
know how to calculate this - you guys
know like the half-life of different
isotopes you see that the radioactivity
declines at a certain point it's also
more cool now so they can put them in
these tanks so they let these tanks hang
outside and this is an OK solution
except for the fact that again we just
have to weigh too much spent fuel to be
able to do this it turns out that if you
were to just keep all the spec filled
that we create in fuel cast it would
take about 300 acres away and which is
absolutely a main and obviously no one
wants to take up that brief a little
side note when I was googling like
images of dry cask storage I was looking
for the different types well I thought
particularly disturbing was that there's
only two types listed vertical storage
and horizontal storage like there's no
other solutions other than these are
giant tanks anyway so people realize
that we need to figure out yet another
way to dispose of the spent fuel
hopefully a way that doesn't get in the
way of people with backyards so their
idea was something called deep
geological repositories their deep
geologic repositories literally just
means that they want to bury the nuclear
waste very deep into the ground and
never be able to retrieve it again so
the main push this was well first of all
it's a permanent method disposal they
hope to put it in the ground never have
to think about again so therefore the
regions that they choose to bury in the
ground have to fulfill a lot of
criterion so this criterion includes not
having a lot of seismic activity because
we are keeping this nuclear waste
underground in these cow
for thousands of years if there is a
huge earthquake those casts break
radiation gets everywhere that's
obviously not a good thing so you know
make sure that doesn't happen
lost have to make sure that there's not
a lot of water that leaks through
because the water can carry the radio
actually I radio I said may be isotopes
and carry them into the vironment which
is something else that we don't want to
do a lot of guys chuckled when you saw
me you come mountain so Yucca Mountain
is like the primary push by the United
States to find a deep geological
repository somewhere in the United
States so we can deal with our fuel so
in 2002 the main push for this began
they spent a lot of money they spent
like billions of dollars finding the
perfect location to put our spent fuel
they had like nine different locations
they finally narrowed it down to Yucca
Mountain they're like yes this is the
one and they started like digging down
deep into nuclear you come out into
making this happen but then things
weren't as peachy-keen as I hoped it
would be
so Yucca Mountain is located in Nevada
people of Nevada weren't happy about
this um they're like why why are we
getting tossed on nuclear waste we don't
even have nuclear reactors in Nevada
this is not there there's a lot of
opposition and because of the social
opposition there was government
opposition and many loopholes had to
jump through and so it's just becoming a
huge disaster they also realized that it
wasn't as geologically sound as I had
hoped there's a lot more ground water
running through and seeping through
Yucca Mountain then they thought there
would be so it's actually not as safe as
I had hoped so there's a huge debacle
basically the costs are rising nothing
much was happening there's a bunch of
different things preventing progression
from happening and then 2011 under the
Obama administration he just called it
quits there's no more government funding
till you come out in it's been abandoned
as you can see from this lovely google
picture it's permanently closed and you
can also see that like 14 people went
out their way to review you come out and
um but we're actually doing okay it's at
3.6 stars just like uh normal like motel
or something like that yeah so that has
been abandoned this idea has currently
been a banned in the United States we're
kind of still looking for other
solutions but we really don't have it
figured out all that well there is one
other kind of way of dealing with
nuclear waste which is repurposing I
personally think nuclear repurposing is
the coolest option out there and
basically repurposing just means you
take the spent fuel you chemically
separate out any material that could be
continuing to be used any fissile
material that could be continuing to be
used in other reactors so basically you
take the spent fuel and it turns out
that 96
of a use fuel assemblies recyclable so
you take the Sun feel you take out what
is useful you throw away what's not
useful which is also still radioactive
waste that has to be put in a fuel pool
or something like that
well you have this precious fuel that
you can like put into another reactor so
this is actually something that France
and other places in Europe and Russia in
Japan they use repurposing quite a lot
for somebody's in the United States
doesn't do it so the reason being is
that this is a really cool idea it's
like recycling it's like very like it's
very clever I think I think it's
personally one of the cleverest
solutions but the issue is is that it's
kind of a really expensive process so
repurposing fuel takes a lot of money
and it turns out that the act of
repurposing fuel actually cost more than
just buying a new chunk of uranium-235
which is why we don't do it's not
economically sound um see ya you guys
have any questions about anything I
mentioned about deposition of nuclear
waste almost done so all these are
issues like we have a lot nuclear waste
to deal with is kind of there is an
inherent danger with using nuclear power
but the real thing that holds us back
from just having nuclear power
everywhere and creating about like 90%
of our electricity as we would hope it
would is economics so in this world
money really matters a lot so the
economics of nuclear power is actually
really complicated topic and it changes
depending on who you talk to there's a
lot of factors that are involved so you
can include certain factors into your
calculations like oh the cost of
building the reactor in the first place
or like the fuel costs our operating
cost and maintenance cost or less the
amount of money that comes out of
damaging the environment you can play
all these different factors in and
everyone turns out a different number so
but basically everyone you talk to you
if you can look at this chart yellow is
nuclear power look gray is coal and the
blue is the natural gas but basically
anyway you talk to you can see that
nuclear is not nearly as economic of a
source of electricity generation as any
other of these ones that I mentioned
unless you talk to UK UK thinks it's
okay but everyone else is saying that
it's not as money efficient so where are
all these costs coming from so the
primary cost actually lies with
something called capital cost so capital
cost is basically the sunk cost of just
building the reactor building reactors
takes billions of dollars it also takes
tons of time and because it takes a lot
of time interest rates also jack up that
and further so basically it's just just
this massive investment they have to
throw in immediately um and this is
where most of the issues lie like it's
really hard to go to investor would be
like hey can I have a billion dollars to
Bill this nuclear reactor it's gonna
take five years and it's gonna take
twenty more years for you to get your
profit back how does that sound no
investor is going to be like yeah that's
a good idea
that's the main reason why we can't get
nuclear up and running we have a lot of
plans and we have the possibility to
create a lot of plants but we just don't
have the money to do so because it's a
huge chunk of money like I mentioned
before it takes a while to get your
profit back and also if for some reason
something happens and you have to stop
building your reactor well you just lost
a billion dollars like there's no
turning back right if you look at this
chart over here which is breaking up the
cost of you can energy per kilowatt hour
I believe you come on our kilowatt hour
kilowatt hour I'll be can see nuclear
coal and natural gas
so this giant went chunk over here
refers to the fuel so if you can look at
nuclear power the majority the cost
actually doesn't come from nuclear fuel
at all it's just about one cent per
kilowatt hour as compared to natural gas
which the majority of the cost of
electricity actually comes from the fuel
if you look at operation of maintenance
again it's not that large of a chunk
it's about the same as maintaining a
coal power plant but then if you look at
the capital cost which is the dark gray
color you can see how massive that is in
comparison to building natural gas and
coal power plants yeah I think that's
the main thing so because it is more
expensive we can't compete with other
forms of electricity people buying the
electricity that's cheapest not
necessarily the electricity that's best
for like grandchildren or something like
that yeah so that's why nuclear power is
it more of a thing and that ends my
pretty lengthy sideshow so do you guys
have any questions about anything I
mentioned if you guys are interested
about any of these topics like if any of
these things piqued your interest I
recommend going to NRC go if they have a
lot of really cool information let me
write that down
because I talked quickly uh-huh that's
basically where I got the majority my
information for the slide show and it is
a reliable source it might just be
skewed a little bit pro-nuclear so just
keep that in mind but there's a lot of
like crazy sources out there on the
website out there on the interwebs take
them with a grain of salt
take NRC gov with less grains of salt
than usual
um or it's one of these things really
the
I interest you guys can take 2204 which
is really cool cost that's offered here
I think this spring and if not the
spring next spring I'll but basically
it's called nuclear power society it's
chopped by a guy named Scott Kemp he
talks about all these things in a lot of
detail and slower so yeah cool so thank
you guys so much for coming I know you
guys could have slept a next hour but
instead you heard me ramble for an hour
you